using tools so I wants to go no but
apparently they use tools like to get
like they'll stick sticks into ant hills
to keep ants but they'll also use rocks
to break things open doing that before I
would imagine apes would follow suit
I think they've that what they're saying
is they're saying officially that
they've entered into the Stone Age oh
boy so like if we are watching if you
saw the human evolved from being a
person that you know what we whatever
the fuck we used to look like when they
first figured out fishhooks grunting to
today you know there's many many
generations of change and all sorts of
different shit that we learned that we
are watching literally the birth of that
separation between like the regular
chimps that are just chillin in the
forest - the chimps that are starting to
figure out tools and weapons right it's
the first day we see a chimp make a
fucking spear a spear sharpen it up and
stab another chimp to death chimps are
becoming woke is that what's happening
it's like they're becoming enlightened
and smarter I don't fit just chimps
there was one with an orangutan it was
amazing a maritime spearfishing
Oh No oh dude you gotta see it it's
pretty I mean it's really crazy but like
it's a beautiful fish it's gonna be
walking down the highway with a
briefcase soon I don't think it's gonna
be there freaky man that freaks me out
but it is so we're witnessing evolution
they're learning things and this one I
think their issue was that this
orangutan had watched fishermen do this
so he had apparently watched some
fishermen like stand on a Ledge and stab
fish so he decided to try to figure it
out himself
that makes sense I mean that's how all
creatures essentially I mean puppies
kittens they all learn it's just it's to
a limit they don't get past that sort of
being able to use tools you get that
picture that's wild bringing up video
too so I thought there might have been
video my dog opened his dog food
container when I was gone
to him a twist a twisted yeah
we did it I gotta get a camera but I I
came home and that top was twisted off
and his belly was like the rang Tang
spearfishing I mean that's crazy
if you saw that in a movie you would say
that is fake that is so that looks like
it's still from Jungle Book
it's amazing it's an amazing photo wish
you get that photo framed Jamie get up
that photo and let's do that that's
really cool name that fucker framed I
talked about this picture all the time
that is so wild so fascinating it really
looks like The Jungle Book